buying things at garage sales and thrift  stores and reselling them on ebay and  amazon so with a thousand bucks you have  to go buy a thousand dollars at a garage  sale and turn into 2 900. take that same  2900 with what you're learning go to  thrift stores dollar stores garage sales  take that to 7 000 seven to fourteen  with a little bag you can't be in  investment mode you have to be in  operational execution mode that's what i  did literally i'm giving you the advice  i did and still real but how do you  think i figured out mug life i was like  i see a lot of mugs at garage sales do  mugs sell for anything search on ebay  mugs completed items sold soared by  [ __ ] price holy [ __ ] there's 88 mugs  there's 63 months there's 96 months then  go buy a bunch of bugs for a quarter  come home look them up educate educate  educate the key to flip life is the  homework you do during the week that you  [ __ ] then leverage on saturday when  you kill it with your [ __ ] knowledge